- So if we all have 24 hours in a day,
we all live on planet
Earth and we all work,
what are you doing with your time?
Success is walking from failure to failure
with no loss of enthusiasm.
You're exactly where
you're supposed to be.
How many of you have let
anxiety get in your way?
I lived in a compromised
home and I became the fruit
of that compromised home.
People are spending money.
You need the skill to
learn how to get them to
spend it with your product or service.
Most people fail to understand
that success takes time.
If you want to be a millionaire,
you learn from a millionaire.
You do not learn from your
uncle who's a janitor.
And wherever there is
fear, there is no faith.
Wherever there is fear, there is no faith.
Well any time you prune anything,
you're going to get much more growth.
If you help other people
get what they want,
then you will get what you want.
- She's a bestselling
author, speaker and TV
and radio show host.
She's made quest appearances
on the Oprah Winfrey Show,
Good Morning America and Forbes.
She's the president and
CEO of Destiny Global.
She's Dani Johnson and here's my take
on her Top 10 rules for success.
- So if we all have 24 hours in a day,
we all live on planet
Earth and we all work,
what are you doing with your time?
Because people like Bill
Gates or the late Steve Jobs,
they lived on planet Earth,
they had 24 hours in a day
and they worked.
Why is it that they
made so much more money
than the rest of us?
Because there is a variable
in the equation of success
and that variable is you.
It's you.
Not your government that
you're working under,
not the boss, not the business,
not the manufacturing,
not the product, not the service, you.
And what you do with what you have.
You see when I first
got started in business,
you know I was a homeless,
broke, fat, cocktail waitress.
Well, the business that kind of presented
itself to me, if you will, I was actually
sitting in my back seat,
it was not something
that I wanted to do, but
as a cocktail waitress,
I knew that I'd be homeless
for another three months
and I knew I would never
pay off my $35,000 in debt
making the amount that I was
making as a cocktail waitress.
So I came to that conclusion.
Hopefully you're coming
to the same conclusion.
This is not going to
work, I have find a way
to generate more income.
Well, that business that was
in the back seat of my car
really wasn't a business,
it was a product.
And it was a product that
I wasn't interested in,
it was a product that didn't work for me,
it was a product that I
had no credibility in,
it was in the weight loss industry.
I was fat.
Who was going to listen to me?
I'm fat, who's going to listen to me?
I didn't even like this product.
That's how come it was
sitting in the back of my car
instead of actually using it.
Well, I didn't believe in it,
I didn't like it, it wasn't my lifelong
dream and passion, it
wasn't the right business
in my opinion at that time,
but I had to step up and
become the right person
in order to get out of
debt, to make more money,
and to make a change in my life.
Rather than waiting around
for someone to sail in
and save the day, yeah, I had
to make some serious changes.
And you know, that's
unfortunate because people
are struggling right now.
They're waiting for someone
to take the problems away.
to change the circumstances.
They're waiting to be found.
They're waiting for somebody to make
all the difference for them.
There is no somebody.
Actually I have to correct myself.
You are the somebody.
We found this quote
from Winston Churchill,
pretty successful man, mmm, pretty famous,
still is famous even though he's dead.
Success is walking from failure to failure
with no loss of enthusiasm.
Whoa, I need to get there.
Walking from failure to failure
with no loss of, hello, enthusiasm.
That's what he calls success.
You see success so much is a mindset.
It's how we think, it's
how we approach life.
It's the decisions that
we make and we live
in a society that has
completely painted this picture
for you and me of what success looks like,
houses, cars, stuff, right?
And then we go and we
charge and get mortgages
and then we go into debt to get that stuff
and now those things
don't feel like success,
they feel like a giant burden.
Why?
Because the path in which they
told us to get those things.
Not only that, do you
really want those things?
Think about it.
Do you really want those things?
Or do you just want them
because somebody else
has told you that that's
what success looks like.
- Be careful what you ask because there
is a price for what you want.
And if you ain't ready.
Joseph was not ready to lead his family
because there were things in him
that had to get worked out of him.
Just like there's things in you
that have to get worked out of you.
There are things in me
that have to be worked
out in me before I can get
to the height of my destiny.
And same for you.
You're exactly where
you're supposed to be.
How many of you have let
anxiety get in your way?
And how many of you through that anxiety
have gone and done other things?
Because things are going fast enough,
it's not moving great enough,
it's not exactly what I
thought it was going to be,
it doesn't look like the
way it was supposed to look.
Come on.
That is a dangerous place to be.
I lived in a compromised home
and I became the fruit
of that compromised home.
And I've paid the price
for those decisions
that I made without all that program.
So I know from a business
perspective that I had to
pull away from all TV,
all bad music so I could
reprogram myself to succeed.
So then naturally when I had my kids,
I did the same thing with them.
Now it wasn't for a Godly reason, friends.
This multi-millionaire is
saying do not watch the media,
do not watch all that junk that is on TV.
It is only going to take you to failure.
Look at what everybody else is doing and
do the exact opposite.
Everybody else is watching TV,
everybody else is watching
their favorite soap,
their favorite stupid sitcom,
everyone else is watching
their favorite talk show.
Everyone else is just
sitting there vegetating
in front of that thing
and they're listening
to music that does not
groom them for success.
25 years ago, the greatest gift I got
was from that man saying
you want to be successful,
you study success, leave
everything else behind.
My family was at Six Flags last weekend.
Oh, my gosh!
Thousands and thousands of people spending
thousands of dollar for
one day of pleasure.
Those are the same people
that are telling you
they can't afford your product or service.
Hello?
They didn't tell Six
Flags they couldn't afford
that expensive ticket or that $10 slurpee.
Give me a break.
People are spending money.
You need the skill to learn how
to get them to spend it with
your product or service.
So don't blame your spouse.
Don't blame the kids.
Don't blame your past,
don't blame your customers,
don't blame anything.
It's time to step up and get the skills
that you need to succeed
because at the end
of the day, you're the one
that has to grow that thing.
You're the one that has
to pay off the debt.
You're the one that's
going to build that career
or that business.
You're the one that's
going to fix the things
in the marriage.
You're the one that it's
all going to fall down to,
so it's up to you to get what you need
so that you can succeed.
Listen, if I can do it
and the tens of thousands
before me who have done it and after me,
then so can you.
People have this mindset
and belief that the only
way they can increase their income is if
they actually go to
college of if, by chance,
that they meet the right people,
if they get lucky, they
marry the right person.
None of that has anything to do with it.
In fact, all of that is a giant myth.
So is overnight success.
Success takes time.
It takes time.
You know, there's that
certain season of the year
where a farmer or even a
gardener is planting seed
in the ground.
It takes time for that seed to germinate.
It takes time for it to become a sprout.
It takes time for it to then start to get
a little bit of strength
and become a stalk
and then eventually it begins to flower
and then through more time,
hello, more and more time.
At the same time, we're
supposed to be nurturing
that seed, I mean that sprout.
We're supposed to be taking
care of it, feeding it,
water it, making sure it's
not getting too much sun
or too much cold.
And so this seed takes
time to go from seed to
the actual fruit.
It takes time.
Some things take longer than others
and most people fail to understand
that success takes time.
If you want to be successful,
don't be listening
to the opinions of those
that are not successful.
If you want to be a millionaire,
you learn from a millionaire.
You do not learn from your
uncle who's a janitor.
Okay?
You don't learn from broke
people about money, you don't.
And we are a product of our environment
and we are who we surround ourselves with.
That's the facts.
So the power of programming.
You see everything that you are today
is who you were trained to be.
You were trained by
messaging that was constantly
coming through music, through
movies, through sitcoms,
all of that stuff completed
architect-ed your mind
and God gave us such a powerful mind
that he says as a man thinks, so is he.
Okay?
So how we think is who we become
and he also said that life and death
is in the power of the tongue.
And we will eat the fruit of what we say.
So what we say about ourselves,
what we say about our kids,
what we say about our spouse,
what we say about life, about politics,
what we say about money like this is
a terrible thing to teach
your kids how to say.
We can't afford it.
We don't have the money.
Okay?
I hate my job.
I hate Mondays, I can't wait till Fridays.
In fact, neurologists have proven they say
that they speech center
of the brain controls
your entire reality.
It controls your entire reality.
I'm being led to do
this with you right now.
Grab a partner.
Is there any men, a big man
in this room by any chance?
Is there a big man in the room.
I don't think I could
do this without a man.
Do we have a man?
(laughing)
That's a big man, now what
were you thinking over there.
(applauding)
Ladies, I feel lead to do this for you
because this is a really
powerful exercise.
So when we say things
like I can't afford it,
I don't have the money, I'm fat.
Somebody was asking me yesterday,
okay where are you, please come up.
What did you do?
Okay, I'm a size six.
I've been a size six for
the last 21 years, yeah.
I was 50 pounds overweight
four times in four years.
My mom was 300 pounds,
I'm sorry 280 pounds.
I'm sorry, both my
sisters were 300 pounds.
I come from an obese
family, do you understand?
So obesity ran in my family and guess
what I thought about myself.
And guess what my stepfather said to me?
That I was fat, I was ugly.
These are the things I
was told and these are the
things that by golly I really believe
and it wasn't until I forgave my dad,
changed the tape of what
was rolling in my head
that I no longer acted like a fat person
because if you think you're fat,
what will you do?
Come on.
As a man thinks, so is she.
As you think, so are you.
So I saw myself fat, I
spoke like I was fat.
Do I look fat in this.
Is my butt too big.
Man, I'm so fat, I have
this, I have that, right?
So when you think like that,
then you start to act like that.
That's how it works, how you think
is how you'll speak, how you speak
is how you act.
So you automatically and
instantly go in the direction
of what you're thinking and speaking.
Therefore, the power of programming.
Sometimes the blessings of
God are completely obvious
and sometimes there's something in us
that likes to fight them.
Sometimes we fight the obvious.
Why do we fight the obvious?
How many of you have
fought the obvious before?
How many of you found out this morning
that you fought a lot, the obvious?
Okay, you're fighting the obvious.
You know what direction
you're supposed to go in
and you don't want to
go in that direction.
It's because of fear and control.
Fear and control is why
we fight the obvious.
We either want the credit
for the success when it comes
or we're afraid that it's
really not going to work
and wherever there is
fear, there is no faith.
Wherever there is fear, there is no faith.
You've got to have faith.
The reality is is that
there are no inhibitors
to your goals, there really is.
There's real life
inhibitors and some of those
inhibitors could be negative people.
Yeah.
Negative people.
But it got to tell you something.
Negative people are
people who and critical
people and judgmental
people are people who
have no goals and no dreams themselves.
You literally need to feel
sorry for these people
because the truth is that out of the mouth
the heart speaks, so when
somebody is inherently critical
and judgmental and condemning
of someone else's dreams
or goals or aspirations or
something that they want to do,
it just shows you who they really are
or actually rather,
who they really aren't.
I used to be one of those very negative,
very cynical, very judgmental people
and I'm so glad that I took the steps
that were necessary for me to
no longer be that negative,
to be that cynical, to
that, ahh, person that
nobody wanted to be around.
Well, the deer came in and ate our squash
as well as our green beans,
but I got to tell you,
there's good news.
Whenever you encounter an
inhibitor to your goals,
something that seems to take them away
or something that seems to I don't know,
stop the growth, well,
in this case, the deer
actually did us a favor
because now what we have
is we have some pruned green beans
and we have some pruned cucumbers.
What does that mean?
Well, any time you prune anything,
you're going to get much more growth.
Did you hear me?
Whenever something is pruned,
you get much more growth.
I've already seen it with my green beans,
which are right over here.
Check this out.
The green beans were attacked
just like the cucumbers.
Well, these were bare just a few days ago.
They were bare.
Now look at all the new
leaves that have come on.
See, you can kind of see
still some of the raw edges
that were bitten or eaten by those deer,
but now what we have is
they are growing again
and they're flourishing again.
And I even found right down
here one little green bean.
I don't know if you can see that or not,
but I'm hoping you can.
There's a green bean.
So, hear me friend.
Hear me, this is the absolute
and I mean absolute truth.
Even if you're saying
that some of your goals,
you feel like you've been digressing,
even if it feels like you have taken major
steps backwards, this is
part of the pruning process
and what follows the pruning process
is much more growth.
So don't get distracted
with those negative people.
Don't get discouraged if
those deer have come in
and eaten some of your vines.
The truth is, keep pressing,
keep moving forward.
- If you help other
people get what they want,
then you will get what you want.
If you're butting heads against your boss,
you're boss wants to see you succeed,
but if you care more
about your bosses success
than you do your own,
your Father in Heaven,
who sees all that you do
and all that you don't do
will bless you.
That's the key to prosperity is to focus
on somebody else's prosperity first.
And yours will come as a direct result
of theirs being there.
Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Roxanne Frazier asked me to,
so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the Top 10 rules
today meant the most to you,
what changes you're going to make
in your business as a result,
leave it in the comments
and I will join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.
(swooshing)